Martin Heidegger is one of the world's
most famous and important philosophers
born in Germany in 1889 he grew to
worldwide fame with the publication of
his great work being and time in 1927
send Reuter Heidegger's thought is his
desire to wake us up to the idea that we
are surrounded by death he didn't use
that word though he preferred the
grander term the noting in German das
Nix this is in existence the opposite of
life we live surrounded by a burden a
scary present through elaborate means by
hiding from the truth that we are so
close to death for the time Heidegger
called life being thus saying existence
or being is finite fragile and very
temporary but we rarely appreciate your
temporary existences much of heidegger's
philosophy is devoted to trying to wake
us up to the fragility of our lives and
the strangeness of existing and this
delicate exhaustible planet spinning in
an otherwise seemingly silent alien and
entirely uninhabited universe at certain
moments of insight and Heidegger wants
us to have lots of things we may think I
am so small so temporary I am a nothing
in a cosmos of lifeless other myths it's
at moments like this that we feel what
Heidegger called the mystery of
existence it can be beautiful it can be
intense most of all it can be terrifying
we live wisely and philosophically by
always acknowledging our precariousness
against the
it isn't just us who are so temporary it
is all living beings or living things
the animals the trees the clouds
they to exist briefly against the
background nothingness once we are aware
that we and all other living things
share this fragile state we might learn
to identify more with them to recognize
our kinship with all living things and
with the earth itself they are like us
briefly alive against the backdrop of
nothingness
the feeling of the unity of all things
might come to you when for example you
see how much connects us with the quail
the shrimp the snail the lamb the pig
the dinosaur normally we separate
ourselves from these others but
Heidegger urges us to see the
interconnections
however heiliger is very aware of the
way in which we hide from a
confrontation with being escaping into
the warm folds of daily life of society
and of what he termed its endless
chatter dasker a day we can imagine
Tasker ADA as an enormous pancake like
dough layer that smothers our connection
with being chatter is everywhere
it comes in via the airwaves the media
our social circle and it seeks to
reassure us that trivia actually matters
that our jobs count that what we are
doing and thinking has importance it
hides us from the nature of being in a
world of death so the task of philosophy
is to remove us from the doughy comfort
of chatter and introduce us
systematically to the bracing concept of
nothingness
Heidegger wants to free us from the full
of chatter so as to focus on the
intensity of existence someone who lives
for the nowhereness of death
Heidegger cause authentic this for
example is an authentic shrimp I can
relate
this is an inauthentic one when I can
lick hype this is an authentic jelly
baby this is an imprint of jelly baby we
know in our hearts that the only way we
can truly appreciate the sign is to
become more conscious of death next day
to day and that we owe it to ourselves
to escape the clutches of escalator for
the sake of I can't locate when asked in
a lecture in 1961 how we might recover
our authenticity
Heidegger reply turtley that we should
simply aim to spend more time in
graveyards